x Playo from Mexico Mexico
yes so D
bit see if I manage
to win another game
today so Catalan
we get game the classic
main variant
now has a huge amount of moves again
Bishop D2 F4 G5 so practically
all the
runner moves yes I always play on that
here is
the somewhat playful Zuch H6 yes,
many people make this mistake, I have
already made it myself, it is completely
pointless, the Zuch if the knight on
C6 can then simply go, now I have to
know, just go
backwards again, such an interesting question is
now here  sometimes knight simply
D4 apart from the fact that I simply
won tempos here
but so knight D4 knight D4 bishop
G2 knight
E6
h FE king yes is probably not a
good structure knight knight bishop
knight E6 dam
D5 how crazy is that
Queen
D5 knight F4 yes  no wait then
I would even have queen
C6
hm knight C7 queen
B7 knight A8 bishop
F1 and knight F8 bishop
F1 that's so crazy I'll try that
out now let's
see okay okay yes so much so much for the
time consumption he just doesn't have it at all
reacts to this idea and
simply put, okay, I accept that
I'm worse off, yes, well, it's
not bad now, probably,
but
like, B2, he has bishop
C3 bishop
D6, yes, that's the easiest move, no,
I just have a little
better development now  and I also have
the idea of ​​winning Queen E4 with very stupidly clumsy
pawns, so then Queen
F3 could answer,
of course, can go to D5, maybe
that's
better that way and now maybe Knight
E4
so he can play Knight C3. No, that
pretty much takes the air out of it
I think, wait a minute, I have the
two bishops C3, yes, okay, if I
play B4 now, what will he do then, what will he do
then all the way back into the
house? Yes, bishop D2, I assume
on knight D2 still has D5 as an
intermediate move, well, he goes  all the
way back so knight die2 still wants to
play of course I could now make a simple Z rook
C8 e.g. then you could
swap knight D2 and make rook C2
with one with a good position
definitely yes
meten
so
okay now he has opened the A-file
of course  Not so nice,
but what do you want to
do
? It can always be so easy to make everything
totally flat,
okay, so now I should get the B2,
but the question is, the two
things are also
weak. It's quite possible that in the end it will be
totally
simplified mhm
Okay, let's try to play actively again first,
maybe so actually I would
like to fight the bbauern war here so that his
own bbauer can win the race,
so now
he can, so he has to be chained to him now, in
principle and the move yes  Of
course it works if I now but can I
now cleverly move the bishop I
can do runner E5
yes you have to get a little
faster you probably can't win that either
but well he just does D5 now
I assume
no one understands that
Now on top of that, I
gave him the bad structure here
or he had it made
so he can play F5 now,
don't do it well, let's see if he keeps
messing around here, he has to
play
F5 now, yes, it's still damned  difficult to
play here somehow to win yes now he has
counterplay here you can't do anything he has
decided not
to fight for time yes can play tower D3 now
and get that one back we're still
too
slow again so here you have to do it
see if you can manage it somehow, well,
taking it can't be wrong. W
here is somehow different, it looks good,
yes,
I don't see anything clear either, it
looks crazy with the double pawn,
but I can also really
attack tower C4 directly, maybe that one  would
have been an idea, well
difficult